I I asked an interview now one of my
interview questions I'm really bad
interview but I'm trying to get better
one of my interview questions is tell me
about it like tell me about one of your
mates they're like what are you on about
give me one of your mates names vanilla
and Adam what does Adam do for work tell
me all about his job and it's genuinely
one of my red or green flags I like that
if they're just like oh I think he uh I
think he works in a warehouse or
something like if you're not curious
about like what your best mate does for
work there's no chance you're gonna call
some stranger and actually like be
inquisitive and curious about them and
what they want to say
foreign